let's assume you've had kovat 19 you
might believe you're immune in the clear
to go about your normal life without
safety precautions but with scattered
reports of recovered cases testing
positive again a lot of people are
wondering if it's possible to develop
immunity at all so can you catch kovat
19 twice the thing is scientists just
aren't sure because figuring that out is
a lot more complicated than you might
think when a pathogen like a virus
manages to get into a human their body
will signal an alarm
this will start what's referred to as
the innate immune response and consists
of physical chemical and cellular
defenses against pathogens often enough
this works and the invader is killed but
sometimes you need a second attack the
adaptive immune response marshals the
Special Forces B cells and T cells B
cells produce antibodies that smother
the specific pathogen so it can't affect
your body cells
so basically antibodies kill a virus
outside of cells killer T cells kill
virus inside of cells so once your body
fights the pathogen what stops you from
having to fight off the same attack over
and over well your body has a secret
weapon to protect you against any future
attacks from the same pathogen memory
cells memory cells are basically the
specialized T cells and B cells that
stick around as guards that way if you
encounter the virus again the army will
be readily waiting to kill that invader
instantly this is immunity a vaccine
works on this basis by adding dead
weakened or fragmented parts of a
pathogen to your body not enough to
cause illness but enough to cause your
body to produce memory cells normally
when you have an infection it's a race
between your immune system and the
infection but if your if you're
vaccinated you've already done the race
part your immune system has already had
time to scale up and
community typically you would know if
you have immunity either from a vaccine
or knowing you previously had the
illness for example it's relatively
straightforward to know whether you've
had chickenpox or not because the
symptoms are highly unique and very easy
to spot but let's presume you know
you've had Kovan 19 you now have
immunity and are safe right to test this
theory one early study infected monkeys
with the kovat 19 virus they then waited
till they tested negative after the
infection passed and tried to reinfect
them when the monkeys didn't become
reinfected researchers concluded that
after one viral attack you would be
protected from another but this isn't a
golden ticket to thinking you're immune
because the length and strength of that
potential immunity are unknown and where
a disease lies on the spectrum is
influenced by two things memory cell
death rate and virus mutation rate
memory cell death rate tells you at what
rate those memory cells may be lost over
time the virus mutation rate can tell
you if the virus will mutate too quickly
for your memory cells the more of iris
mutates the more unrecognizable it
becomes to your memory cells determining
where kovat 19 falls on this timescale
is a vital step in managing its spread
one indication of how long its immunity
might last is to look at other corona
viruses those who have contracted SARS
one have been found to have immunity for
about two to three years and the same
time frame has been seen in other corona
viruses that can cause the common cold
yet early signs have shown that this
virus tends to mutate slowly but there's
another indicator into immunity strength
and length the serology tests the
serology testing is is a blood test for
the presence of antibodies against that
specific virus or that specific disease
importantly these are tests that can be
done after you've recovered from
symptoms and you don't have to know
exactly when that person was infected
and so that's a very powerful way to
count how many people have actually been
infected whether they recognized the
symptoms or not these tests can measure
how many antibodies are in the sample by
looking at how they block or respond to
the virus these measurements can help to
understand immunity levels and how long
immunity could last for example studies
for many other viral infections have
found that the more severe the case the
longer the immunity basically the bigger
the end
affection the bigger the immune response
and more antibodies in a sample which in
turn gives longer immunity but this may
not hold true for kovat 19 it certainly
may not be as simple as if you're
positive for the antibody you're
protected against the disease you're
immune that's true for many infections
it's not proven for Kovac 19 disease and
the effectiveness of certain serology
tests for Coppa 19 has been mixed some
tests are being misused and others were
brought into the United States before
the FDA could approve them the result
has been poor detection rates some as
low as 20% you know these are the same
types of tests as a pregnancy test and
so there's no way people would take
pregnancy tests if they were only
accurate 60 percent of the time and
there have been instances of false
positives which can be extremely
dangerous because they are people with a
false sense of potential immunity but
these problems aren't universal and the
FDA has begun approving a select few
that show much higher accuracy so with
an accurate serology tests would you be
immune well one early Chinese study
found 30% of those who tested positive
for the virus had little to no
detectable antibodies which would
suggest that immunity isn't guaranteed
though this has been challenged by
another study that found all patients
tested had significant antibody levels
but other issues such as age or health
could play into these responses is it
gonna be point one percent of people who
can get reinfected three months later or
is it going to be a higher number in the
elderly
once more accurate and universal testing
is underway more studies can begin to
more precisely examine how long this
immunity may last and who has it so our
best bet right now is to keep our
distance and assume we're not immune at
all
[Music]